so um when you were a young man you know
if you wanted to sort of experience
world building you'd play Dungeons and
Dragons or read a comic book today it
seems when kids kids wanted younger
readers wanna experience world building
they go to video games do you see video
games as a threat to fantasy writers
like yourself who are presenting whole
worlds and like books like the world of
Ice and Fire for people to investigate
or video game some that you think are
eating away at writing or challenging
what you do video games video games are
addictive
that's I don't play many video games but
and it's not because I don't like them
it's because when I did play a few I
liked them too much I would lose months
to video if somebody would give me a
video game and I'd start playing it and
then I'd I'd be killed and I'd have to
play it again and then I have to play it
again next day I know it's like you know
7:00 in the morning I've been up all
night on blurry-eyed
I'm still playing this damn one one more
time one more reboot here you know to
play the video game so I finally said no
I better I better stop doing that but uh
I do see kids who have the same same
reaction you know who really get into
video games that being said I think
ultimately video games are gonna become
a new art form I don't think they're
there yet they're fun they're not art
but they could be art you know we had
last year we had the premiere of season
4 Game of Thrones right here in New York
and we had the premiere party afterwards
then oculus rift was at that premiere
party with these uh this virtual reality
thing that they'd built where you send
it in the cage up the side of the wall
you know you put on this headset and
then you get in this cage and you send
up the side of the wall and the wind
buff at you and the cage sways and you
know you you walk on the wall and the
wildlings shoot arrows at you and then
you fall to your death it was it's only
like 30 seconds long or whatever however
long it was but it was so realistic and
so immersive that it was incredible and
you know ultimately you you Wed that
technology with video games and you can
have an adventure and experience that
you will live because I mean here you
could you could see it you could feel it
because the cage was rocking
they had wind machines that would you
know just like the wind howling along
the wall you could feel the cold winds
so they really had a lot of sensory
stuff going on now it's still a very
primitive technology it's a technology
and in its infancy but when you take the
the plots and the world-building of
video games and you couple it with that
ultimately you will get um an
entertainment medium you know not on
unlike many science fiction writers have
predicted a long time ago where you'll
put yourself in a sensory deprivation
tank or something like that and it'll be
you're actually living some adventure
where you have you're not just reading
an author's event but you're you're
choosing you're making your own
decisions you're going wherever it is
you're in a different world I imagine
the first ones to really pioneers
technology will be the porn guys because
porn always seems to lead every
technological innovation here from from
videos to you know to CDs to to whatever
to the internet now but ultimately will
be used for all sorts of things and
hopefully at some point we'll get a
shakespeare who will make a true art
form out of it and will make a game that
will be totally immersive I wouldn't
even you won't even call it a game
anymore it'll be I don't know what you
call it but will that effect what I do
will that effect books or television or
films hard to say I don't know
books are still around the their death
has been predicted numerous times
you know films were gonna kill books
they didn't so television was gonna kill
books it hasn't the internet what's
gonna kill books no that hasn't worked
out either books are hanging in there
what art forms do die you know this does
not I have a lot of vaudeville to see
here in New York at the moment radio
drama is is pretty well wiped out so
what will happen when this new art form
comes
we'll find out I don't think it's gonna
happen in my lifetime but some of you in
the audience may may live to see it